PURPOSE AND THAT WAS TO SERVE
THIS COUNTRY.
>> THE CHIEF AND OTHERS WHO WORK
WITH SINGH SAY HE LOVED BEING A
POLICE OFFICER.
HE LOVED HIS FAMILY, AND HE WAS
"LIVING THE AMERICAN DREAM."
LISA?
LISA: THANK YOU, JONATHAN.
AND SINGH’S CHIEF RANDY
RICHARDSON BREAKING DOWN EARLIER
TODAY WHILE SPEAKING ABOUT THE
MURDERED OFFICER.
WATCH THIS.
>> YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THIS
WAS NOT SUPPOSED TO HAPPEN HERE.
I’VE BEEN TO TOO MANY OF THESE
FUNERALS, AND I NEVER THOUGHT,
EVER, THAT I WOULD HAVE TO BE
DOING THIS.
I DO NOT WANT TO BE HERE TODAY.
I WOULD GIVE ANYTHING NOT TO.
I DID NOT KNOW CHRISTMAS MORNING
AT 4:00 IN THE MORNING, WHEN I
SAID GOODBYE TO HIM, AND SENT
HIM OFF TO HIS FAMILY, THAT IT
WOULD BE THE LAST TIME THAT I
SAW HIM.
MY DEPARTMENT IS HURTING.
WE’RE STRUGGLING THROUGH THIS.
SO PLEASE BE IN MIND WHEN YOU
SEE THEM.
THAT’S IT’S HARD FOR THEM.
WE’RE A FAMILY.
WE’RE NOT AN AGENCY.
LISA: JOINING ME NOW EXCLUSIVELY
IS STANISLAV SHERIFF.
>> HELLO, LISA.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME ON THE
SHOW.
LISA: OUR HEARTS BREAK FOR YOU
COMMUNITY.
I DON’T KNOW HOW ANYONE COULD
WATCH THAT WITHOUT BREAKING DOWN
THEMSELVES IN TEARS.
MY HEART GOES OUT TO YOU.
RANDY SAID IT WAS A CLOSE-KNIT
COMMUNITY AT THE NEWMAN POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
YOU CAN OBVIOUSLY SEE THE LOVE
AND ADMIRATION THAT HE HAD FOR
OFFICER SINGH.
I WANT TO START OUT WITH HIS
LEGACY, HONORING HIM AND WHAT HE
MEANT TO YOU AND THE NEWMAN
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
CAN YOU TELL ME ABOUT CORPORAL
SINGH?
>> WELL, I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE
SHERIFF’S OFFICE IS THE LEAD
INVESTIGATIVE AGENCY, AND WE’RE
FULLY SUPPORTING THE NEWMAN
POLICE DEPARTMENT, SO EVEN
THOUGH I’M THE SHERIFF, CHIEF
RICHARDSON IS REALLY TRYING TO
KEEP HIS TEAM TOGETHER AND WE’RE
THERE TO SUPPORT HIM.
OFFICER SINGH IS THE SHINING
EXAMPLE OF WHAT IMMIGRATION IN
AMERICA SHOULD BE.
THIS IS A YOUNG MAN WHO
IMMIGRATED HERE LEGALLY.
IT WAS HIS DREAM TO COME TO
AMERICA.
IT WAS HIS DREAM TO BECOME A
POLICE OFFICER.
HE WORKED HARD TO ACHIEVE THAT
GOAL AND UNFORTUNATELY HE
SACRIFICED HIS LIFE TRYING TO
DEFEND AND PROTECT HIS
COMMUNITY.
NEWMAN IS VERY SMALL.
IT’S ALMOST LIKE MAYBERRY.
THESE CRITICAL INCIDENTS DON’T
OCCUR AND FOR THIS LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY, IN THE
HISTORY OF ITS EXISTENCE, THIS
IS THEIR FIRST LINE OF DUTY
DEATH.
LISA: SIR, HE LEAVES BEHIND A
WIFE AND 5-MONTH-OLD CHILD.
CAN YOU TELL US A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HIS FAMILY?
>> HE’S GOT A WONDERFUL FAMILY.
I THINK WHAT CHIEF RICHARDSON
SHARED WITH EVERYONE, YOUR
VIEWERS AND THE NATION AND EVEN
HERE LOCALLY, SPEAKS TO THE
CHARACTER OF OFFICER SINGH AND
HOW MUCH HE LOVED HIS FAMILY.
I THINK THE PHOTOGRAPH SPEAKS
VOLUMES TO HIS DEVOTION NOT ONLY
TO HIS FAMILY BUT HIS COMMUNITY.
LISA: JUST TELL US MORE ABOUT
HIS DEDICATION ON THE JOB.
I READ THAT HE DROVE 2 1/2 HOURS
TO ATTEND THE POLICE ACADEMY
WHICH HE PUT HIMSELF THROUGH.
HE TOOK LESSONS TO LEARN HOW TO
SPEAK ENGLISH BETTER SO HE COULD
MOVE UP THE LADDER.
CAN YOU TELL US A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THE DEDICATION?
>> HE DID.
IT’S AN AMAZING STORY.
HE DIDN’T START WITH THE NEWMAN
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
HE WAS A CADET WITH THE TURLOCK
HE WORKED VERY HARD.
HE WAS A RESERVE WITH THE MERCED
COUNTY SHERIFF’S OFFICE.
HE PURSUED HIS DREAM AND TO GET
THROUGH THE ACADEMY HE WAS
WILLING TO MAKE THAT COMMUTE
EVERY DAY, TO COMPLETE THAT
TRAINING PROGRAM, MAKING HIM
ELIGIBLE TO BE A PEACE OFFICER
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND YES, HE KNEW THAT HE WAS
DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND BECAUSE
OF HIS ACCENT.
AND AGAIN, HE THREW EVERYTHING
INTO LANGUAGE CLASSES, ENGLISH
IS NOT HIS FIRST LANGUAGE.
AND EVEN I REMEMBER WHAT HE
SOUNDED LIKE ON THE RADIO, AND
WE ALL KIND OF -- ALL CHUCKLED
ABOUT THAT ACCENT AND HOW HARD
HE WORKED TO ENSURE THAT HIS
LANGUAGE GOT BETTER, HIS ENGLISH
SKILLS GOT BETTER, BECAUSE
A POLICE OFFICER, AND HE WORKED
AGAIN, HE WANTED SO BADLY TO BE
DILIGENTLY TO ACHIEVE HIS GOAL.
LISA: WHERE DOES THIS MANHUNT
STAND NOW?
>> SO WE HAVE IDENTIFIED A
SUSPECT, ALTHOUGH WE’RE NOT
NAMING THAT SUSPECT, PRIMARILY
BECAUSE WE HAVE A VERY SPECIFIC
PROTOCOL THAT WE USE TO MAKE
POSITIVE IDENTIFICATIONS, AND AS
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE USE MULTIPLE
ALIASES.
OFTENTIMES PEOPLE SHARE SIMILAR
OR SAME NAMES, AND WE’RE NOT
GOING TO MAKE A MISTAKE, SO
WE’RE NOT READY TO ACTUALLY NAME
THE SUSPECT, BUT WE HAVE
MULTIPLE TEAMS UTILIZING OUR
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
PARTNERS, STATE AND LOCAL
PARTNERS.
WE HAVE MULTIPLE TEAMS OUT
CHASING DOWN MULTIPLE
INVESTIGATIVE LEADS.
WE HAVE A HOTLINE SET UP AND
WE’RE WORKING NONSTOP, WE’RE NOT
SPARING ANY EXPENSE, TO HUNT
THIS SUSPECT DOWN AND BRING HIM
TO JUSTICE.
LISA: ARE CALIFORNIANS IN DANGER
RIGHT NOW?
>> NO, THEY AREN’T.
YES, THIS SUSPECT IS ARMED AND
DANGEROUS, BUT WE BELIEVE HE’S
ON THE RUN.
WE HAVE NO EVIDENCE WHATSOEVER
TO BELIEVE HE’S STILL A CREDIBLE
THREAT, ALTHOUGH I SUSPECT WHEN
LAW ENFORCEMENT MOVES IN HE
MIGHT BE.
BUT WE ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC,
THERE IS PLENTY OF INFORMATION
OUT THERE, IF YOU SEE HIM OR YOU
THINK YOU SEE THIS SUSPECT, DO
NOT APPROACH HIM.
DON’T ENGAGE HIM.
DON’T TRY TO STOP HIM.
CALL 911 AND LET US COME
INTERCEPT HIM, BECAUSE WE WANT
TO GET HIM INTO CUSTODY SAFELY
WITHOUT ANYBODY ELSE BEING
INJURED OR KILLED AS A RESULT OF
THIS INVESTIGATION OR THIS
INCIDENT.
LISA: DO WE KNOW IF THE SUSPECT
HAS A CRIMINAL BACKGROUND?
>> NOT YET BECAUSE AGAIN, WE’RE
WORKING ON THAT POSITIVE
IDENTIFICATION, AND SO WITHOUT
COMPLETING THAT PROTOCOL, WE
DON’T WANT TO MISIDENTIFY
ANYBODY SO WE’RE GOING TO MAKE
ABSOLUTELY SURE THAT WE HAVE AN
IDENTIFICATION.
REALLY, THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT
IS FINGERPRINTS AND WE WON’T
HAVE THAT UNTIL WE GET HIM IN
CUSTODY.
LISA: I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
SOMETHING YOU BROUGHT UP AT THE
PRESS CONFERENCE.
YOU MADE A DISTINCTION THAT
CORPORAL SINGH CAME HERE.
HE CAME HERE FOR THE SOLE
PURPOSE OF BEING A POLICE
OFFICER AND SERVING THIS COUNTRY
AND COMMUNITY.
YOU DREW A DISTINCTION BETWEEN
THE SUSPECTED KILLER WHO CAME
HERE, BROKE THE LAW AND CAME
HERE ILLEGALLY.
WHY WAS IT IMPORTANT FOR TO YOU
DRAW THAT DISTINCTION?
>> BECAUSE I WANT THE NATION TO
KNOW, I WANT YOUR VIEWERS TO
KNOW, THAT OFFICER SINGH REALLY
SHOULD BE THE FOCUS OF THIS
INVESTIGATION AND HIS SACRIFICE,
BUT I ALSO WANT EVERYBODY TO
KNOW THAT IMMIGRATION IS GOOD
FOR AMERICA.
IF DONE LEGALLY.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION DOESN’T
SERVE OUR COMMUNITIES,
ESPECIALLY CRIMINALS WHO VICTIM
TIES AND EXPLOIT OUR
COMMUNITIES.
WHETHER YOU HATE THE PRESIDENT
OR LOVE THE PRESIDENT, BORDER
SECURITY GOES HAND-IN-HAND WITH
NATIONAL SECURITY.
THE SAFETY OF OUR COMMUNITIES,
AND PUBLIC SAFETY.
WE NEED TO KNOW WHO IS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT SHOULDN’T BE.
WE SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY WITHOUT
POLITICAL INTERFERENCE.
AND THERE IS ONLY ONE WITH
ENTITY THAT CAN FIX IMMIGRATION,
EVEN THOUGH THERE ARE LAWS ON
THE RULE OF LAW AND WE SHOULD BE
THE BOOKS AND WE SHOULD STAND BY
ENFORCING THOSE LAWS, CONGRESS
IS THE ONLY ENTITY THAT CAN FIX
THIS PROBLEM, AND UNTIL THEY
DECIDE TO DEE POLARIZE
THEMSELVES AND FOCUS ON WHAT’S
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
PEOPLE YOU CAN’T ESTABLISH A
SYSTEM OF IMMIGRATION THAT LACKS
BUREAUCRACY, HOPEFULLY, AND
ALLOWS PEOPLE A PATH TO BECOME
GOOD CITIZENS AND CONTRIBUTE TO
WHAT MAKES AMERICA GREAT.
OFFICER SINGH, HE IS THE
ABSOLUTE POSTER CHILD FOR WHY
IMMIGRATION WORKS IF DONE
LEGALLY, AND PROPERLY.
LISA: SHOULD MORE BE DONE AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER TO PREVENT THIS
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY?
>> WELL, I THINK THERE IS, AT
LEAST FROM WHAT I KNOW, THERE IS
A LOT OF GREAT WORK GOING ON, ON
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
I THINK IT’S INEXCUSABLE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO ATTACK THE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO ARE THERE, EITHER AS
MEMBERS OF U.S. CUSTOMS, THE
BORDER PATROL, ICE, OR OTHER
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
PARTNERS.
STOP DEMONIZING AND VILLAINIZING
THEM.
IT’S TIME TO COME TOGETHER AND
FIX THE PROBLEM AND, YES, BORDER
SECURITY NEEDS TO BE A PRIORITY
AND IT’S NOT JUST THE
IMMIGRATION ISSUE, LISA.
WE HAVE CARTELS THAT ARE
TRAFFICKING NARCOTICS, WEAPONS,
LITTLE GIRLS, WE HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
WE NEED TO SECURE OUR BORDERS
AND WE NEED TO GIVE THE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO PROTECT US, OUR
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
PARTNERS, THE ABILITY TO DO
THEIR JOB WITHOUT POLITICAL
INTERFERENCE.
LISA: CALIFORNIA HAS COME UNDER
FIRE FOR BEING A SANCTUARY
STATE.
HAS THAT HAMSTRUNG YOUR ABILITY
TO DO YOUR JOB IN ANY WAY?
>> OH, CERTAINLY IT HAS.
FIRST, AND AS I TOLD THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
WHEN I SAT NEXT TO HIM, I DON’T
THINK WE SHOULD BE SUBJECTED TO
POLITICAL INTERFERENCE.
I UNDERSTAND WHY THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND POLITICIANS HAVE
DECIDED TO CREATE THESE LAWS
BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE THAT PEOPLE
NEED TO BE PROTECTED.
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS HERE TO
PROTECT PEOPLE.
BUT YOU CAN’T PROVIDE SANCTUARY
FOR CRIMINALS.
ALL THAT DOES IS SILENCE THE
VOICES OF OUR VICTIMS, AND I
CERTAINLY DIDN’T SIGN UP TO DO
THAT.
REMEMBER THAT OUR PARTNERS WITH
ICE, GREAT, GREAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS, THEY ARE
NOT IN MY COUNTY SWEEPING
THROUGH CHURCHES AND SCHOOLS AND
CONVENIENCE STORES.
THEY ARE ONLY INTERESTED IN THE
FUGITIVES AND THE CRIMINALS.
WHY ARE WE PROVIDING SANCTUARY
FOR PEOPLE WHO VICTIMIZE AND
EXPLOIT THE WEAK AND THE
DEFENSELESS?
WE SHOULD NOT BE DOING THAT.
LISA: BEFORE I LET YOU GO IS
THERE ANY PLACE WHERE VIEWERS
AND PEOPLE AT HOME CAN HELP THE
SINGH FAMILY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IF YOU GO TO OUR FACEBOOK PAGE,
JUST SEARCH FOR THE STANNIS
JUST SEARCH FOR THE
STANNISSLAW --
WWW.STANISLAUSSWORN.com DEPUTIES
ASSOCIATION, THAT’S THE ONLY
OFFICIAL SITE WHERE PEOPLE CAN
ABSOLUTELY DONATE AND HELP THIS
FAMILY.
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE’RE GOING
TO HELP THIS FAMILY.
THERE ARE BENEFITS AVAILABLE TO